John what's on the slate for the second
half of 2013 so first is that I think
we've talked about the release of bhama
too so and I think we've kind of covered
that a bit then I'm also producing a
documentary about breast cancer which is
being shot mostly in Baltimore but we
also went to catania sicily to film the
festival of st. Agatha who's the patron
saint of breast cancer and that is you
know we're going to be done cutting the
film hopefully you know in the fall and
with an idea and I towards releasing in
October 2014 but what's interesting to
me about that project besides the
directors really amazing is that the
film to to me when I heard what the
director wanted to do with the film is I
immediately said you know that's not a
film that's a transmedia project and
that your films and she wants to do this
verte film about these particular
characters is is this one thing but that
all these other expansive ideas that
she's had and we've developed during
discussions are part of a larger project
which is going to be what is
short-handed called a breast cancer
world map where we're actually going to
be seeding that with stories extra
stories that we filmed through our
production but we're going to also our
first foray to expand that is to go to
India and to film a hospital and a
doctor in patients in Mumbai and then
also encourage other women from around
the world to upload their stories and in
addition to that we're going to have
kind of a historical timeline to breast
cancer treatment because the dot the
director teaches at Johns Hopkins so she
has access to the Johns Hawk Hopkins
archives medical imagery archive and
actually the person who invented the
mess
me actually was a surgeon at Johns
Hopkins so there's a fair amount of
material there and plus we have as part
of the one of I'm one of the transmedia
producers but we just brought on another
transmedia producer who is a well-known
breast cancer doctor who teaches a Duke
and as part of that has worked with NIH
and he's connected to organizations and
governments related to breast cancer
throughout the world and so he's in the
process of connecting us to those
organizations and helping us develop
this world map which won't will have a
human face in a story face as a strong
component of it but will also have a
strong data component as well in terms
of potentially we'll see epidemiological
data as well as organizations who helped
you know who provide assistance to
people who are suffering from breast
cancer and survivors of breast cancer so
that's something which is you know which
is kind of one of my main focus is now
and then also i'm doing my first
workshop in africa this this summer in
South Africa the Durban Film Festival
and so that's my fifth continent for my
workshops so I'm very excited about that
and the only continent missing is Latin
America so you know Brazil Argentina
Chile Colombia etc you know time to time
to make that happen so I can you know
add you know so i can be semi complete
in my continents for the workshops and
and then also we're probably going to be
having the workshop my my think outside
the box office workshop come out online
you know because i've been traveling so
much frankly for the breast cancer
documentary that I've actually been not
been doing as many workshops and you
know and it's time to just get the thing
up online so people can access it for I
don't know what we're going to price it
out but it's going to be pretty
reasonable so that people can access it
from wherever you know in the world
and I won't then have to travel and
maybe we'll do something similar to
films where we'll have the workshop
online but maybe there will be a skype
you know it's that whole thing about
added value that we were talking about
earlier you know that maybe there will
be an extra fee for a skype session with
me or you know something along this or
maybe aspect discussion group where a
people to get together and we do a
series of you know google chats as part
of that and maybe we'll be doing that as
part of the that might be a crowdfunding
reward you know actually if we you know
if I do the crowdfunding campaign for
vomit you know i'll probably be offering
certain of my you know other services
from my other brand as part of to
enhance the vomit crowdfund campaign you
know because i realize i have to
audiences i have a you know a film you
know the film distribution and marketing
audience and people were interested in
that and then you know vomit has its own
brand of people interested in graffiti
and street art who probably aren't so
interested in this other aspect so so
that's pretty much what's happening for
the next you know year and then I have
another you know I have a food project
that I'm working on and then you know a
few other projects here and there could
you know filmmakers consultancies that
you know that I still do you know I
still work with an additional one or two
filmmakers a month you know do whatever
I have to the time for you know in
addition to these other larger projects
but part of like my long-term aim is to
get one of the things I'm excited about
the breast cancer documentary is that
the transmedia project is so robust is
because I do want to move into that
realm and one of the things I don't know
if you know if I did this last year as I
consulted on some of the early stages at
the Star Trek transmedia that transmedia
campaigned for star trek into darkness
and they actually ended up only keeping
my call to action you know that I
developed and and then they didn't do
anything else which was sad but you know
that are you the 170 one is I can say I
feel at least
am i proud that I contributed to that
even though the number is not I would
not have I did not choose that number of
the 1701 we had chosen a different
number but I think I'm allowed to say
that I'm on an NDA but I think it's all
I haven't said anything that's in
violation of my NDA you know and now
you're speaking in San Francisco yeah
yeah in the media future like in the
next two days I'm going not speaking I'm
participating in Ted's Ted hopes artists
entrepreneur workshop that he's doing up
there where it's bringing together tech
people distribution consultants and
filmmakers into a kind of a lab
environment and then I'm still doing the
ifp filmmaker labs day so I do that you
know that doing that this year probably
keep on doing that and that's really
funny I still run into filmmakers that
you know have good films like I just ran
into a doc filmmaker that is perfectly
positioned to be in the ifp lab they
have a great project and like they
didn't even apply it's just like what
are you guys doing apply it's like it's
for film first-time filmmakers it's free
they give you lots of stuff and it's
like you know the applications are in
the spring and the lab start in late
spring early summer it's like you know
you should film makers you should apply
for all these labs that are out there
there's there's so many opportunities
for filmmakers in terms of labs and
contests and things like that now maybe
people have too many that they're
involved in but there's a lot of you
know there's a poor Sundance but there's
a zillion other ones
you